the Joe Rogan experience so when you
asked about dumb moments though but you
know I had one where I had this like
cascading sense flood of love to her I
was thinking about my family I was
thinking about my son and my wife and my
parents and and you know it sounds like
so banal and one of the things that
happens is that these platitudes that
look to the everyday wonders and
psychedelics you know it softens those
habits and and helps you get out of
those grooves and for me that was really
useful and it's only I think it's the
experience of ego dissolution that
allows you to because your ego enforces
those habits and you get a little break
there was a beautiful metaphor one of
the scientists I interviewed in the book
a Dutchman working in in Imperial
College in London he said thinking your
mind is a hill covered in snow and your
thoughts are sleds going down that hill
and after a while after a lot of
thoughts have gone that Hill they'll be
these grooves and then getting to get
deeper and deeper in a certain point you
can't go down the hill without slipping
into those grooves that's who we are as
we're like you know at this age and what
psychedelics do he said is is flatten
the snow lots of fresh powder and you
can then take the sled any way you want
to go that's a great way of man I've
always talked about predetermined
patterns and grooves that people fall
into so it's amazing hearing them say it
that way but that's a much better way of
describing it like snow yeah the sliding
these thoughts down these already
existing patterns that's amazing that's
you know of what you said about love and
and and being cynical that's so
important too because there's something
that's something that people are they
avoid sincerity like there's something
about it that it makes you too
vulnerable or too open to criticism or
too open to ridicule and we're worried
about being sincere and I do think that
that's one of the primary benefits of
psychedelics yeah we live in an ironic
culture and we defend ourselves against
strong experience or a self exposure
by adopting this stance that's ironic
and
cool and psychedelics is not a cool
experience it's the opposite well it's
cool when it's over yeah
but yeah it's it's serious stuff
[Applause]